in kürze wird österreich weitere
soldaten nach mali in zehnten das
derzeitige kontingent besteht aus 27
personen
sie sollen im rahmen der eu
hauptsächlich zur ausbildung malischer
soldaten eingesetzt werden
auch wenn diese friedensmission für
manche überraschend wirkt sie fügt sich
nahtlos in die reihe österreichischer
beiträge zum internationalen frieden
heute in vechta kompakt auslandseinsätze
des österreichischen bundesheeres die
[Musik]
teilnahme österreichischer soldaten an
internationalen einsätzen gehört bereits
seit 1960 zu den kernaufgaben des
bundesheers was mit dem sanitäts
kontinent im kongo begann hat sich
mittlerweile zu wesentlich
umfangreicheren und gefährlicheren
einsetzen weiterentwickelt einen
rasanten anstieg gab es 1972 73 von
circa 100 auf über 1100 mann etwa
112.000 österreicherinnen und
österreicher haben bisher an insgesamt
124 friedens unterstützenden oder
humanitären missionen im ausland
teilgenommen
dabei sind auch 52 soldaten ums leben
gekommen
die aufgaben und rahmenbedingungen haben
sich im laufe der zeit stark geändert
wir sind der 1990 er jahre handelt der
sich primär um beobachter einsätze zu
überwachung von bad von stillstands
abkommen im östlichen mittelmeer und im
nahen osten
das bundesheer war lange zeit mit einem
bataillon also mehr als 250 mann auf
zypern im einsatz
mit knapp 400 soldaten auf den
golanhöhen jeweils im auftrag der
vereinten nationen
heute befinden sich nur 5 auf zypern das
gelang kontingent wurde 2013 abgezogen
der eu beitritt und die teilnahme der
nato partnerschaft für den frieden 19 95
vor allem aber die kriege im ehemaligen
jugoslawien haben die situation
grundlegend verändert so wurden bereits
1996 über 300 mann nach bosnien
herzegowina entsandt um bei der
herstellung von sicherheit und beim
wiederaufbau zu unterstützen
im kosovo ging ist nach den blutigen
kämpfen im sommer 1990 dar um für
sicherheit zu sorgen
die rückkehr von hunderttausenden
flüchtlingen zu ermöglichen
österreich stellte gleich zu beginn 35
soldaten für die multinationale k4
private südwest
der westbalkan liegt im besonderen
interesse österreichs deshalb sind auch
2009 10 mehr als drei viertel des
auslands kontingentes dort eingesetzt
eine zäsur brachten die terroranschläge
von 2001 sie führten zur internationalen
intervention un friedensmission in
afghanistan gefolgt von einsätzen in der
demokratischen republik kongo im tschad
und im libanon
die anforderungen stiegen enorm nicht
nur an die vor ort befindlichen
soldatinnen und soldaten sondern auch an
die logistik und führungskräfte zu hause
friedenseinsätze dienen unverändert der
herstellung von internationaler
sicherheit und frieden
eine zentrale aufgabe ist mittlerweile
der schutz von zivilpersonen darüber
hinaus geht es immer häufiger um den
aufbau von lokalen fähigkeiten und
kapazitäten
denn letztlich so in einheimische kräfte
für sicherheit und entwicklung sorgen
können
extremismus und terrorismus soll damit
der nährboden entzogen werden und
bessere lebensbedingungen den
auswanderungs druck reduzieren
stabile nachbarregionen und die
eindämmung von migration nach europa
liegen im besonderen
sicherheitspolitischen interessen
österreichs will österreich damit
erreichen österreich bekräftigt durch
die teilnahme an diversen
friedenseinsätzen seine bereitschaft
einen solidarischen beitrag für den
internationalen frieden zu leisten
es untermauert damit auch den standort
der vereinten nationen sowie der osze in
wien und stärkt die eu als sicherheits
akteur
daher steht das bundesheer im april 2009
10 mit 203 soldaten in un-missionen 507
im rahmen der nato pfp 381 für die eu
drei für die oecd und einem soldaten für
den stabilitätspakt in südosteuropa im
einsatz insgesamt versehen so mit 1095
soldaten ihren dienst im ausland davon
22 frauen die umfangreichsten einsätze
sind kaffee im kosovo in bosnien
herzegowina
wie viele im libanon sowie - ma und eu
tm in mali egal unter welcher flagge sie
dienen unabdingbare voraussetzung ist
ein mandat des sicherheitsrats der
vereinten nationen
das sind ein einsatz legitimiert dadurch
kann auch österreich teilnehmen ohne
gegen die neutralität zu verstoßen
ein ausblick in einer broschüre des
generalstabs heißt es zu internationalen
einsätzen krisen begegnen wo sie
entstehen
das europäische umfeld stabilisieren und
österreich als verlässlichen partner
verankern
laut sicherheitsstrategie sind 1100
soldaten dafür bereitzustellen
angesichts aktueller unsicherheiten und
gefahren wird das österreichische
bundesheer somit weiterhin mannigfaltige
aufgaben an verschiedensten schauplätzen
zu bewältigen haben
denn ein erfolgreiches internationales
krisenmanagement bringt nicht nur
verbesserungen vor ort sondern auch
einen sicherheitsgewinn für europa und
österreich